la nuit l'oeil humain voit plus d'un
millier des toiles mais deux jours nous
n'en voyons qu'une le soleil notre
étoile
le soleil est l'étoile la plus proche de
la terre c'est la source d'énergie au
centre du système solaire
un réacteur nucléaire qui chauffent les
éclaire notre monde et dont toute chose
et tout être vivant dépens
dans les cathédrales de l'astronomie
nous collectons sa lumière et nous
l'étudions comme les alchimistes étudié
nord
pour les anciens le soleil était un dieu
la science nous a appris autre chose
nous savons que les arbres les plantes
sont nourris par la lumière solaire qui
nous fournit nourriture et oxygène
le soleil est à 149 millions de km de la
terre
la distance idéale pour que la vie
fleurissent sur notre planète il faut à
la lumière du soleil
huit minutes et demie pour nous
atteindre
pourtant même ici où le soleil n'est
qu'une pointe de lumière son influence
est déterminante
nous sommes sur un satellite de la
planète neptune
il faut plus de quatre heures à la
lumière pour atteindre cette zone
lointaine et glacé le soleil est à
presque 5 milliards de kilomètres
pourtant le soleil est assez fort pour
faire fondre la glace à la surface de ce
satellite et faire jaillir des geysers
de gaz dans le ciel
un vent souffle du soleil un jet de
particules chargées électriquement qui
voyage bien au delà des planètes jusqu'à
mi-chemin de l'étoile la plus proche
ce vent solaire est prisonnier à
l'intérieur d'une bouteille géante
invisible le champ magnétique du soleil
les planètes ont également des champs
magnétiques
voici les lignes de force de neptune
elles forment un bouclier qui repousse
le vent solaire et l'éloignent de la
planète
le vent solaire a un effet plus direct
sur les comètes qui ne sont pas protégés
par des champs magnétiques
elles sont balayées par des particules
en provenance du soleil des formes d'une
longue queue qui s'étend sur des
millions de kilomètres
pour en savoir plus sur notre étoile un
vaisseau spatial baptisée ulysse a
profité du rebond on gravit sionnel de
jupiter pour venir se placer bien en
dessous de leurs beats des planètes
c'est une mission vers l'inconnu à la
fin de 1994 pour la première fois la
sonde observer le pôle sud du soleil
la mission du lys d'une durée de cinq
ans pouvait commencer
il allait observer le pôle nord étudier
le vent solaire et mesurer les forces
immenses qui bloque les protubérances
qui jaillissent du soleil
et ulysse allait observer ce que les
astronomes ne pouvait avoir les lignes
de force magnétique ici en bleu qui se
tordent et s'enchevêtrent avec la
rotation du soleil
notre soleil offre de nombreux visages
nous voyons comme ça une boule jaune de
gaz incandescents qui tourne sur elle
même en un mois à travers le filtre
rouge de l'hydrogène chaud il devient un
globe du multi et agité en perpétuel
changement
et vu aux rayons x il est le théâtre
d'explosions brillante un chaudron
d'énergie
sur la terre la nuit noville bray comme
des vers luisants pendant quelques
heures nous remplaçons la lumière du
soleil par des lumières artificielles
pourtant c'est l'énergie du soleil que
nous brûlons l'énergie du soleil
conservé par la terre la lumière du
soleil a nourri il y à des millions
d'années des organismes qui aujourd'hui
fossilisés nous servent de carburant le
charbon le gaz le pétrole qui nous
fournissent notre électricité
pour les anciens le soleil était un
calendrier il avait remarqué que le
soleil se levait chaque jour à un
endroit différent
mais deux fois par an pendant deux ou
trois jours le soleil se levait au même
endroit c'était le milieu de l'été et le
milieu de l'hiver et à partir de ses
points de repères fondamentaux
il savait quand ils devaient moissonnée
et ce n'est
quand l'endroit du levé reprenait sa
course sur l'horizon la saison était sur
le déclin
il était sage de suivre le soleil
aujourd'hui nous avons d'autres raisons
de suivre le soleil voici le télescope
solaire de kitt peak en arizona
ici la lumière du soleil est collecté
par un système de miroir puis à travers
un système de contrôle de la température
qui empêchent ou distorsion de l'image
la lumière est renvoyé dans les
profondeurs de la terre
là les astronomes la mesure chaque jour
les miroirs au dessus maintiennent
l'image solaire stationnaire et
parfaitement nette
l'image la plus importante est un arc en
ciel ce sont les couleurs de la lumière
son spectre regarder de près le spectre
de la lumière et vous verrez des raies
elles sont la signature des éléments qui
constituent le soleil
et elles nous fournissent des
indications sur sa température sa
vitesse de rotation et son activité
magnétique
ici la marque rouge de l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène est l'élément principal
composant les étoiles est donc à
l'origine d'une grande partie de la
lumière du soleil
cette lumière se précipite vers nous à
la vitesse de 290 7000 kilomètres à la
seconde
si le soleil n'était qu'une boule de gaz
son spectre serait un simple arc en ciel
mais ce n'est pas le cas les gaz plus
froid présent dans les couches externes
du soleil absorbe la lumière des gaz
plus chaud en dessous des raies révèlent
leur présence en les comparant à des
signatures chimiques produites dans
leurs laboratoires
les savants peuvent identifier les
différents éléments du soleil ils
comprennent l'hydrogène qui forment les
trois quarts du soleil avec le sodium le
magnésium et le potassium
le soleil est immense six groupes le
disque terrestre tiendrait plus de 100
fois sur le disque solaire
des boucles de gaz appelé protubérance
s'élève dans l'espace et il ya souvent
des taches solaires signes indicateurs
d'activités internes l'intérieur du
soleil est un réacteur nucléaire au
centre où l'hydrogène se transforme en
hélium la température est de 14 millions
de degrés l'énergie se déplace lentement
vers la surface
d'abord par radiation puis plus près de
la surface par des vagues de convection
comme de la soupe bouillante dans une
casserole à la surface la température
n'est plus que de 6 mille degrés au delà
se trouve l'atmosphère externe du soleil
sont à l'eau sa couronne
sacramento peak au nouveau mexique à
2700 mètres d'altitude un obélisque
dressé vers le soleil
ce n'est pas un hôtel mais un
observatoire au dessus des nuages où
l'homme observe les tâches du soleil
c'est ici que l'on peut obtenir les
images les plus nettes de l'astre du
jour
elle entre par la tourelle et sont
réfléchies par un tube sous vide dans la
fraîcheur de la montagne afin de limiter
au maximum le chatoiement du soleil on a
fait le vide dans le tube sous terre les
observateurs dirige la lumière vers une
batterie d'instruments situés dans les
profondeurs de la terre
dans cette catacombes de la science
naissent des images des tâches du soleil
ces éruptions qui apparaissent de temps
en temps à la surface du soleil
on raconte qu'en 1610 galilée failli
perdre la vue en essayant de les voir
aujourd'hui à sacramento pic
ces observations sont méticuleuse
deux taches solaires ont reflété sans
danger en noir et blanc sur une table
d'observation
oh
couleur une tache solaire ressemble à un
tournesol au centre l'ombre plus sombre
parce que la température y est 1600
degré plus froide que l'océan de chaleur
jaune qui bouillonne autour et forment
la photosphère
plus proche la pénombre une enveloppe de
pétales qui sépare l'ombre de la
photosphère une tache solaire comme
celle ci pourrait avaler la terre
un groupe de taches solaires d'habitude
elles se forment en une dizaine de jours
et disparaissent en deux semaines
certaines durent plusieurs mois en
période calme
il peut ne pas y en avoir du tout
une chaîne complexe de taches solaires
peut s'étendre sur 160 mille kilomètres
la moitié de la distance de la terre à
la lune et elles peuvent durer très
longtemps le temps de faire plusieurs
fois le tour du soleil
porté par sa rotation mensuel
les plus petites tâches ne dure qu'un
jour ou deux il y en a une au centre de
cette photo d'un diamètre de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres
elle est à peine visible au milieu des
remous de la photosphère
les taches solaires sont plus froides
que la photosphère mais même si le
soleil était recouvert de ses tâches il
brille ray avec la même force
le nombre de taches solaires suit un
cycle de onze ans
à gauche le soleil sans tache à droite
avec un maximum de tâches pendant la
plus grande partie du xviie siècle le
soleil n'avait aucune tâche et l'europe
connaît une brève période glaciaire il
est possible qu'un lien existe entre les
taches solaires et le climat
le champ magnétique du soleil est
responsable de la présence des taches
solaires pendant la rotation du soleil
ces lignes de force magnétique se
tordent et s'enroulent quand ces lignes
traversait surface la photosphère des
tâches apparaissent
et parce que les lignes de force sont
courbés à travers la photosphère un
autre phénomène apparaît comme des
aimants en forme de fer à cheval de
grand arc de gaz suivent les boucles
magnétiques
des taches solaires jumelles révèle
souvent les points de sortie et d'entrée
du lignes de force un spectre solaire
comme celui ci révèle l'activité
magnétique à travers une tache solaire
ici des formes en y à verser indique une
intensité
plusieurs milliers de fois plus
importante que le champ magnétique de la
terre
mais les questions restent encore à
élucider que se passe-t-il dans les
tâches solaires et pourquoi sont elles
plus froide que la photosphère dans
laquelle elles se développent les lignes
de force qui crée une tache solaire
emprisonne et ralentissent les gaz qui
se trouve à l'intérieur des gaz plus
lent signifie des températures plus
basses et des températures plus basses
entraîne des couleurs plus sombres la
force magnétique est également
responsable des pénombres en forme de
pétales qui jaillissent des tâches il
s'allonge comme de la limaille de fer au
voisinage d'un aimant
ces taches solaires ont été filmés dans
de lumière différente ici une lumière
invisible maintenant dans la lumière
rouge de l'hydrogène alpha
les deux images montrent des normes arc
suivant des lignes de force magnétique
dans la photosphère grésillante chaque
bulle jaune est aussi grande que la
france
en dessous nous plongeons vers le pire
du soleil de la surface au coeur il y à
presque 800 mille kilomètres
au centre la fusion nucléaire des noyaux
d'hydrogène se transforme en hélium la
fusion est provoqué par l'immense
chaleur et la pression
le centre du soleil ressemble à une
bombe à hydrogène les noyaux d'hydrogène
se cogne avec une telle force qu'il
fusionne et se modifie
chaque seconde 600 millions de tonnes
d'hydrogène se transforme en 596
millions de tonnes d'hélium les 4
milliards de tonnes qui manque se
transforme en énergie une toute petite
partie suffirait à fournir de l'énergie
aux états unis pendant un an
mais comme si elles nageaient dans du
sirop il faudrait plus d'un million
d'années à une seule particule de cette
énergie pour zigzaguer à travers la
densité du colosse solaire et il lui
faudrait un million d'années pour
atteindre la chromosphère l'atmosphère
rouge qui entoure le soleil quand
l'énergie d'expulser sous forme de jets
de gaz
les températures s'élèvent de six mille
degrés dans la chromosphère inférieur à
près de 500 milles plus loin
cet aileron de baleine est une
protubérance une éruption d'hydrogène
s'élevant dans la chromosphère
en voilà une autre
celle ci en noir et filmé sur fond de la
photosphère la surface du soleil
comparé à la taille de la terre cette
protubérance traverse complètement la
chromosphère
comme une prairie en feu les
protubérances balance dans le champ
magnétique du soleil elles peuvent
mesurer plusieurs millions de kilomètres
et
de nombreuses protubérance sont
suspendus à des arcs magnétique
voici la vue la plus spectaculaire de la
chromosphère une éruption solaire
développant l'énergie de 10 millions de
bombes à hydrogène
ces éruptions solaires éjecte d'énormes
quantités de matière à des millions de
kilomètres heure
ces particules énergétiques sont l'une
des principales sources du vent solaire
voici l'autre source des explosions au
niveau de la couronne l'atmosphère
externe du soleil
comme un arrosoir le vent solaire
vaporise un jet de particules chargées
en électricité vers les planètes
elle met un ou deux jours à atteindre la
terre mais elles sont en grande partie
repoussé par la magnétosphère sauf à la
hauteur des pôles magnétiques ou les
particules spirale vers le bas
elles forment deux couronnes ovale
autour des pôles magnétiques nord et sud
en réagissant avec la haute atmosphère
terrestre
les particules nous offre un spectacle
de lumières merveilleux les aurores
dans l'hémisphère nord celle aurores
boréales et dans l'hémisphère sud
l'aurore australe
des orages magnétiques aux orages de
pluie l'affluence du soleil est présente
partout ils sont causés par des charges
électriques augmentant dans l'atmosphère
quand l'air chaud s'élève à chaque
seconde sur terre un millier d'orage
produit une centaine d' éclairs le
soleil contrôler notre climat
l'air chaud s'élève au niveau de
l'équateur et se dirige vers les boules
à mi chemin il rencontre de l'air froid
qui descend lui vers les moteurs de
cette rencontre naissent les fronts et
les dépressions météorologiques
les vents ne soufflent pas directement
du nord vers le sud car ils sont
détournés par la rotation vers l'est de
la planète
voici la couche d'ozone le gaz qui nous
protège des rayons ultra violet
dangereux du soleil au dessus de
l'antarctique un trou s'est formée dans
la couche d'ozone les émissions de gaz
cfc industrielle en sont peut être
responsable
ce trou dans la couche d'ozone nous
rappelle combien est fragile notre
relation avec le soleil
une ombre balle et la terre
c'est l'ombre de notre lune qui passe
directement en face du soleil une
éclipse totale se prépare
alors qu'on est en plein jour un
crépuscule surnaturel s'installe
venus de partout des astronomes
observent ce phénomène
hélas les faits diamant quelques
secondes avant que la lune de recouvre
entièrement le soleil
changement de diaphragme et pendant
quelques précieuses minutes
la couronne externe du soleil est
visible nous regardons à allonnes
particules hydrogène de plusieurs
millions de km de large
la brillance de la couronne est égal à
l'éclat d'une pleine lune
c'est une coïncidence incroyable que la
lune recouvre exactement le soleil lors
d'une éclipse totale
mais aujourd'hui les astronomes n'ont
plus besoin d'attendre une éclipse
totale pour étudier la couronne du
soleil dans les pyrénées ils créent leur
propre éclipse
à l'intérieur de ce dôme se trouve à
coronographe inventé ici par des
astronomes solaire dans les années 30
ils ont pensé à insérer un disque opaque
dans un télescope pour imiter une équipe
ce total maintenant ils peuvent voir une
éclipse quand il le désire et
enregistrer le drame qui se joue à la
surface du soleil
pendant cette période en utilisant la
même méthode
des vagues de gaz avancent et reculent
sur la couronne comme la houle sur le
rivage
observez aux rayons x le soleil est une
boule d'énergie les taches blanches sont
les vastes convulsions qui nourrissent
116 la couronne
la naissance du soleil a pu être
déclenchée par les ondes de choc
consécutive à l'explosion d'une étoile
c'était il y a cinq milliards d'années
et un nuage de gaz et de poussière s'est
peu à peu concentré
à l'intérieur du nuage se trouvait toute
la matière nécessaire à la formation du
soleil et des planètes
quand le nuage s'est condensée sa
gravité a augmenté un énorme complexe de
matières s'effondrant sur lui même
la matière les plus denses au centre de
20 de plus en plus chaudes et des
réactions nucléaires si nice hier
au delà des tourbillons de matières
formes et les planètes du système
solaire
aujourd'hui le soleil atteint l'âge
adulte dans 5 milliards d'années il
commencera à manquer d'hydrogène
le soleil changera progressivement de
couleurs et grossira mercure et vénus
sans bras sous les océans de la terre se
mettront à bouillir
le soleil sera alors une géante rouge
consommant ces dernières réserves
d'énergie pourtant alors que la vie
c'est d'un drap sur terre elle naîtra
peut-être ailleurs
titan est un satellite en orbite autour
de saturne aujourd'hui c'est une planète
gelée
pourtant ces composants chimiques riches
pourraient engendrer la vie réchauffé
par la géante rouge
quittant pour et s'éveiller à la vie
mais seulement pour un temps
il aura consommé toute son énergie le
soleil s'effondrera lentement sur lui
même
il deviendra une naine blanche un
cadavre d'un plus gros que la terre
mais sa mort offrira un dernier
spectacle le dernier jet de gaz du
soleil mourant projettera une nébuleuse
dans la galaxie
un rond de fumée cosmique un dernier
souvenir de l'étoile qui nous a donné la
vie
bon
e